FEMALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
creative commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today, we're going to generalize
our discussion of
series to cover series of
functions rather than series
of just constants.
In other words, you'll notice
that, up until now, what we've
been doing in our discussion of
series was have a bunch of
fixed numbers and
then add them.
You see, in the same way that
one starts with constants and
ordinary arithmetic and then
starts talking about
functions, the same thing occurs
here, that maybe we are
now interested in a series
over a range of different
values of 'x'.
Now, rather than to talk
abstractly about this, I'd
like to return to a topic that
we touched upon briefly much
earlier in the course, and then
come back to that topic
with far greater power
than we were able to
exhibit up until now.
And it's the idea of
approximating a function by
polynomials.
In other words, this question
of degree of contact.
And again, rather than review
that abstractly, let's talk in
terms of a picture.
You see, today's lecture
is called polynomial
approximations, and
the idea is this.
Let's suppose we have the curve,
'y' equals 'f of x'.
It's smooth.
It passes through the origin.
And we're told the following.
We say, look, we're interested
in approximating this curve in
a neighborhood of 'x' equals
0-- in other words, at this
point here--
by various polynomials.
Now, the simplest polynomial,
of course, is a constant.
In other words, the question
is, how should we choose a
straight line, 'y' equals a
constant, 'y' equals ''P sub
0' of x'-- in other words,
a polynomial
of degree 0, a constant--
if we want the best possible
horizontal line that
approximates the curve at
this particular point?
And I think you can see that
it's rather trivial at this
case to say, OK, let's take
the horizontal line that
passes through this point.
See, any other horizontal line
misses this point altogether.
OK, so far, so good.
Then somebody says, now, look
it, if we remove the
restriction that the line be
horizontal, what about any
straight line?
What straight line has the best
degree of contact with
the curve at this particular
point?
In other words, what first
degree polynomial has the
highest degree of contact
over here?
Now again, sparing
you the details--
because the details are
supplied in the text--
the polynomial there
is simply what?
'f of 0' plus ''f prime
of 0' times 'x''.
In other words, it's
a tangent line.
The basic equation of a tangent
line is 'y' equals 'mx
plus b', where 'm' is the slope,
which is 'f prime of
0', and 'b' is the y-intercept,
which is
'f of 0' over here.
Now, the next question
comes up.
What if we wanted a quadratic
polynomial, a second degree
polynomial that fits the curve
even better, in other words,
has a greater degree
of contact at
this particular point?
Let's label that 'y' equals ''P
sub 2' of x' to indicate a
second degree polynomial.
And to analyze what that
polynomial must look like,
let's simply write down some
undetermined coefficients
here, namely, let's let 'P2 of
x' be 'a0 plus 'a1x' plus 'a2
'x squared''.
And the idea is to determine
what 'a0', 'a1', and 'a2' must
look like if this polynomial is
to have a maximum degree of
contact with the curve,
'y' equals 'f of x'.
Now, what do you mean by maximum
degree of contact?
Well, what you mean is you
want the function at 0 to
equal the given function at 0.
You want the first derivative
of 'P2' evaluated at 0 to
equal the derivative of
'f' evaluated at 0.
And you want the second
derivative of 'P2' evaluated
at 0 equal to ''f double
prime' of 0'.
Well, let's go through
this in slow motion.
First of all, 'P2 of
0' is simply 'a0'.
'P2 prime' is simply 'a1 plus '2
a2 x'', and evaluating that
when 'x' equals 0, we
just have 'a1'.
So 'f of 0' must equal 'a0'.
'a1' must equal 'f
prime of 0'.
Now, what about the
second derivative?
Notice that every time we
differentiate this polynomial,
another term drops out.
'a0' drops out the first time,
'a1' the second time.
And when you've differentiated
this term twice, all you have
left is '2 a2'.
In other words, 'P2
double prime'
evaluated at 0 is '2 a2'.
That must be 'f double
prime' of 0.
Equating these two, 'a2' must
be the second derivative of
'f' evaluated at 0 over 2.
I inadvertently wrote in 2
factorial here, which is the
right answer, but I haven't led
up to that yet, so if you
want to call this
2, that's fine.
At any rate, here's
what I've shown.
What I've shown is that, if
you want the polynomial of
degree 2 that fits the curve the
best, in a neighborhood of
0 comma 'f of 0',
this is how the
coefficients must be chosen.
And in fact, this situation
generalizes very nicely.
You see, suppose you want the
n-th degree polynomial
expression.
Differentiate this 'n' times.
You see, each time you
differentiate, one of these
terms drops out.
What happens to this term
as you differentiate it?
The first time you differentiate
it, you bring
down an 'n'.
The next time you differentiate,
you bring down
an 'n minus 1'.
By the time you've
differentiated 'n' times, this
is 'x to the 0', that's 1, 'a
sub n' is still here, and 'n'
times 'n minus 1' times 'n minus
2', et cetera, is just
what we call 'n factorial'.
In other words, the n-th
derivative of ''P sub n' of x'
is 'n factorial' times
'a sub n'.
If you evaluate that at 0,
that's still 'n factorial'
times 'a sub n'.
That must also equal the n-th
derivative of the function
evaluated at 0, by definition
of what you mean an n-th
degree of contact.
At any rate, that says that
the n-th coefficient, the
coefficient of 'x to the n',
must be the n-th derivative of
'f' evaluated at 0 over
'n factorial'.
By the way, notice
what this says.
And we'll come back to this
much more strongly later.
It says that, for this
coefficient to exist, the n-th
derivative of 'f' at
0 has to exist.
In other words, if 'f' does
not possess its n-th
derivative, this particular
equation doesn't make sense.
And I'll show you what that
means in a little while.
But at any rate, notice that
what we've now shown is that
''P sub n' of x'--
if you want to use the
sigma notation--
can be written how?
Well, it's the sum as 'k' goes
from 0 to 'n', the k-th
derivative of 'f' evaluated at 0
over 'k factorial', times 'x
to the k-th' power.
Which written out longhand
is simply what?
'a0' plus 'a1x' plus ''a2 'x
squared'' over '2 factorial''
plus et cetera, the n-th
derivative of 'f' evaluated at
0 over 'n factorial'
times 'x to the n'.
And what we do is we let 'P of
x' denote the limit of ''P sub
n' of x' as 'n' goes
to infinity.
In other words, for a fixed
'x', we look at what the
sequence converges to as 'n'
goes to infinity, and we
denote that as a series.
You see, what happens is 'x' is
a variable here, but if you
replace 'x' by a specific
number, what's inside the
summation sign becomes a
constant which depends only on
'n', and we're back
to our study of
ordinary series again.
Now, what does 'P of x'
mean in this case?
Going back to our diagram, it
means that, as we let n get
bigger and bigger and we
determine more and more
coefficients, we get what?
Hopefully, what's a better fit
to the curve over here, that
we get a greater degree of
contact every time we tack on
the next term in the series.
Now, because this may seem a
little bit abstract, let's
illustrate this thing
numerically.
Let's pick a specific example.
And I'll pick an easy
one to compute.
Let 'f of x' be 'e to the x'.
After all, what could
be easier?
Because the derivative of 'e to
the x' with respect to 'x'
is just 'e to the x', so the
n-th derivative of 'e to the
x' is always 'e to the x'.
When 'x' is 0, 'e
to the 0' is 1.
So the n-th derivative
of 'e to the x',
evaluated at 0, is 1.
If I divide that by 'n
factorial', I just get '1 over
'n factorial''.
In other words, the sequence
of polynomials that
approximates 'e to the
x' is given by what?
Summation ''x to the k' over
'k factorial'' as 'k' goes
from '1 to n'.
And again, what this
means is what?
The first approximation is
the line, 'y' equals 1.
The straight line approximation
for the highest
degree of contact at
the origin is 'y'
equals '1 plus x'.
The best quadratic approximation
is 'y' equals '1
plus x plus ''x squared'
over 2'.
The best cubic fit is when 'y'
is '1 plus x plus ''x squared'
over 2', plus 'x cubed over
6'', 6 being 3 factorial.
And we can continue on this way,
getting better fits as we
add more and more terms.
And again, I've spoken quite
rapidly, the reason being that
this part is done superbly in
the textbook, complete with
graphs, tables, and
what have you.
Now, here's the question.
The question is, look it,
we can compute 'Pn of x'
for any given 'n'.
And we intuitively get the
feeling that, as 'n'
increases, 'Pn' hopefully will
look more like 'f of x'.
In other words, what we would
like to do is to be able to
compare, or better still, to
study 'f of x' by comparing it
with the limit of 'Pn of x'
as 'n' goes to infinity.
In other words, what we hope
will happen is that 'f of x'
looks like ''P sub n' of x'
for large values of 'n'.
Now, we don't know where this
is going to happen.
In fact, the remainder of our
course now revolves about
three questions.
The three questions
are the following.
First of all, does the limit,
'Pn of x' as 'n' approaches
infinity, exist?
In other words, does 'P of x'
exist in the first place?
Does this limit always exists
for a given 'x'?
Secondly, suppose the
limit does exist.
How do we know it's going to
equal the given function, 'f
of x', which it's trying
to approximate?
In other words, how do we know
that we don't get an
approximation which is nice near
the point of contact, but
then, no matter how far out
we go beyond the point of
contact, the approximation
doesn't become
sufficiently good?
See?
And the third question that
comes up, assuming that the
first have been answered, is
suppose the limit does exist--
in other words, suppose this
limit function, 'P of x',
which is a limit of 'Pn of x'
as 'n' approaches infinity,
does exist--
the question is, does 'P'
possess the polynomial
properties that each piece
of 'n' possesses?
In other words, the question
is, does the limit of a
sequence of functions have the
same property that each of the
members of the sequence has?
For example, every polynomial
is continuous.
The question, for example, that
might come up is, is the
limit of a sequence of
continuous functions also
continuous?
Now, at first glance, it might
seem as if these are rather
trivial to answer.
Let me proceed next by showing
that the answer can be no to
each of these three questions,
after which we'll then try to
show when the answer
will be yes.
The idea is this.
Let me call these things
counter-examples, even though
I don't know what better
word to use here.
In other words, let me show
you an example where the
answer to each of questions
one, two, and three
happen to be false.
For example, let 'f of x'
be '1 over '1 minus x''.
As a review in taking
derivatives, 'f prime of x'
would be '1 minus x' to the
minus 2 power, ''f double
prime' of x' would be
2 times '1 minus x'
to the minus 3 power.
See, in other words, you bring
down the minus 2, but the
derivative of what's inside with
respect to 'x' is minus.
So a minus times
minus is plus.
Similarly, the third derivative
of 'f of x' is 3
factorial, 2 times minus 3 times
minus 1, '1 minus x' to
the minus fourth.
And in general, the n-th
derivative of 'f', in this
case, is 'n factorial' times
'1 minus x' to the what?
Minus 'n minus 1'.
In other words, notice that the
magnitude of the exponent
is one greater than the number
we're taking the factorial of.
At any rate, if I now compute
the n-th derivative of 'f'
evaluated at 0, I just
get 'n factorial'.
And if I divide 'n factorial'
by 'n factorial', I get 1.
In other words, every one of
my coefficients of the
approximating sequence of
polynomials is going to be 1.
In other words, the
approximation for 'f of x',
where 'f of x' is '1 over '1
minus x'', is simply what?
'Pn of x' is '1 plus x plus 'x
squared'', et cetera, plus et
cetera, 'x to the n-th' power.
Now, here's the interesting
point.
This part is irrelevant.
I just wanted to show you
something over here.
Notice that 'f of 2'
is clearly minus 1.
If I replace 'x' by 2
over here, 1 over 1
minus 2 is minus 1.
On the other hand, what I claim
is that the limit of a
sequence, ''P sub n' of x', as
'n' goes to infinity doesn't
even exist when 'x' is
2, because look what
happens over here.
When 'x' is 2, this is what?
1 plus 2 plus 2 squared plus
et cetera '2 to the n'.
That's 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus
8 plus 16, et cetera.
And as I let 'n' go to infinity,
that sum increases
without bound.
In other words, here's an
example where the given limit
didn't have to exist.
In other words, the sequence
of polynomials does not
converge at all at
'x' equals 2.
So much for showing that
the answer to the first
question can be no.
As for the second question,
let's define a function as
follows, to show you why
continuity is so important.
Let 'f of x' be 'x squared'
if 'x' is less
than or equal to 2.
And let it be 4 if 'x'
is greater than 2.
Now, if we compute the
derivatives of 'f' evaluated
at 0, we find that what?
'f of 0' is 0.
See, 'x squared' at 0 is 0.
'2x' at 0 is 0.
The second derivative here
is 2, so ''f double
prime' of 0' is 2.
And the third derivative and
higher, since this is only 'x
squared', are identically 0.
In other words, notice that the
second derivative of 'f'
evaluated at 0 is 2.
All other derivatives are 0.
In other words, notice that
'Pn of x' is equal to 'x
squared' when 'n' is
greater than 2.
And that's a straightforward
computation.
I will drill you on the homework
problems to show you
how to get more facility.
We're doing these things.
But here's the key point.
Let's look to see what the limit
of 'Pn of x' is as 'n'
approaches infinity.
Since 'Pn of x' is equal to 'x
squared' for all 'n', in
particular, then, since this
doesn't depend on 'n', the
limit off 'Pn of x'
as 'n' goes to
infinity is just 'x squared'.
What this says is this.
Our function, 'f of x',
graphs like this.
The sequence of polynomials--
which, by the way, converge
to the limit
function, 'x squared'--
look what they do.
They're just 'y' equals
'x squared'.
In other words, somehow or
other, when we got to this
sharp corner-- in other words,
notice that 'f of x' is not
differentiable at this point--
our sequence of polynomials
blissfully went right on their
merry way smoothly while
the function itself
leveled off like this.
In other words, the limit
function always exist, but as
soon as 'x' is greater than 2,
in this example, the function,
'P of x', no longer is
the same as 'f of x'.
You see, 'P of x' is going up
like this, 'f of x' has just
leveled off this way.
There are even more glaring
examples, but I will leave
those for the supplementary
notes to go
into in more detail.
But so far, we've seen what?
That the answers to questions
one and two can be no.
Let's now show that the
answer to question
three can also be no.
Let's define a sequence of
polynomials, ''P sub n' of x',
to be 'x to the n', where the
domain of 'P sub n' is the
interval from 0 to 1.
What that means is something
like this.
See, here's 0, 0.
And I hope this reminds you of a
homework problem that we had
very early in the course, but
that's irrelevant whether it
does or not.
'P1 of x' would look
like this.
'P2 of x' would look
'P3 of x' would look
like this.
In other words, all of
these curves pass
through 0, 0 and 1, 1.
But as 'n' increases,
the degree of
contact here gets better.
At any rate, let's take a look
at the limit function.
'P of x' is the limit of
''P sub n' of x' as
'n' approaches infinity.
'x to the n', as 'n' approaches
infinity, well, if
'x' is less than 1 in magnitude,
'x to the n-th'
approach is 0.
On the other hand, if 'x' is
equal to 1, 1 to the n-th
power is still 1 as 'n'
approaches infinity.
Therefore, 'P of x'
would be what?
It's 0 if 'x' is greater than or
equal to 0 but less than 1.
And it's 1 if 'x' equals 1.
Now, here's the key point.
Observe that, since 'Pn of x'
is a polynomial, it's, in
particular, continuous.
In other words, each
'P sub n' is a
continuous function, unbroken.
On the other hand, look
at the limit function.
It's 0 all the way up to 1.
And that 1, the function
jumps to 1.
In other words, graph-wise,
the thing looks like this.
This is a graph, 'y'
equals 'P of x'.
It's 0.
All of a sudden, it jumps.
Is the limit function,
therefore, continuous
with 'x' equals 1.
And the answer is no.
There's a jump discontinuity
here.
In other words, observe that
each 'P sub n' is continuous
when 'x' equals 1.
The limit function exists,
but it isn't continuous
when 'x' equals 1.
In other words, the properties
of a sequence of convergent
functions do not have
to be inherited
by the limit function.
That shows, then, that the
answer to our three
questions can be no.
What we would like to do is
find out when and if the
answer will be yes.
What we shall do for the
remainder of today's lesson is
answer the first
two questions.
And this, by the way, is also
done very nicely in the text.
The third question, for some
reason or other, is beyond the
scope of the text.
We will discuss this in our
future lectures, plus the
supplementary notes.
In fact, that the answer to
question number three will be
the end of our course, when
we finally answer
that particular question.
But at any rate, what I'm saying
now is let's spend the
remainder of today's lesson
in showing how to answer
questions one and two in the
affirmative, and we'll save
question three for the
remaining lectures.
The first thing I'd like to
point out is the role of the
ratio test and absolute
convergence.
Namely, given the series
summation 'a n 'x to the n''--
And by the way, if you haven't
noticed this by now, it's
rather conventional sometimes,
to save time, not to put the
subscripts on here.
But if it bothers you, I mean,
I could do things like this.
It's just that to save time and
space, I sometimes will
not put the subscripts
on here.
But at any rate, let's just talk
about this for a moment.
Notice that a series converges
as soon as it converges
absolutely.
The point is that, for a
positive series, I can use the
ratio test or its equivalent.
Namely, for example, what I can
do is to test summation
absolute value, 'a n 'x to the
n'', for convergence by the
ratio test, by the comparison
m by the
integral test, et cetera.
And what I'm saying is, if
that particular series
converges, then the original
series, namely, the one
without the absolute value
signs, converges absolutely
for that same value of 'x'.
Well, again, instead of talking
about that, let's look
at a particular example.
And it looks like I've scraped
the blackboard
here a little bit.
Let me just--
The first example is this.
Let's suppose you look at
summation n goes from 0 to
infinity, absolute value of
'x to the n-th' power.
By the way, notice that this is
a geometric series with a
ratio absolute value of 'x'.
Consequently, the series
converges if and only if the
absolute value of 'x'
is less than 1.
By the way, let me make
a little aside here.
Many people would tackle this
problem by the ratio test, as
I hinted at over here.
Namely, let the n-th term be
the absolute value of 'x to
the n-th' power.
Then the 'n plus first' term
would be the absolute value of
'x to the 'n plus
first'' power.
Then the ratio between these
two would be the absolute
value of 'x'.
Therefore, row, which is this
limit, would be the limit of
the absolute value of 'x'
as 'n' goes to infinity.
That's just equal to the
absolute value of 'x' itself.
And for convergence, notice that
row must be less than 1,
and that says what?
The absolute value of 'x' must
be less than 1, just
as we did over here.
I simply would like to make a
little aside over here, and
that is, if you use this
particular approach, that
comes under the heading of
circular reasoning, because
you may recall when we proved
the ratio test, we did it by
comparing the series with the
geometric series, which meant
that we already had
to know that the
geometric series converged.
And this is a geometric
series.
But that's an aside which I just
wanted to mention to you
in forms of circular
reasoning.
The important point to
observe is what?
That this series converges if
the absolute value of 'x' is
less than 1.
Consequently, that means that
the series without the
absolute value sign converges,
in fact, absolutely, if the
absolute value of 'x'
is less than 1.
In other words, for this
particular series, '1 plus x
plus 'x squared' plus 'x
cubed'', et cetera, that will
converge to a finite limit
function if the absolute value
of 'x' is less than 1.
Let's look at another example.
Suppose we look at the absolute
value of 'x to the
n-th' power over
'n factorial'.
If we look at this, the nth term
is the absolute value of
'x to the n-th' over
'n factorial'.
The 'n plus first' term,
therefore, is the absolute
value of 'x to the 'n plus
1'', over ''n plus 1'
factorial'.
Therefore, the ratio between
the 'n plus first' term and
the n-th term is the absolute
value of 'x' over 'n plus 1'.
Rho is this particular limit.
Well, the limit of the absolute
value of 'x' over 'n
plus 1', as 'n' approaches
infinity--
and here's the key point.
Notice that 'x' is a fixed but
finite number once we get
started here.
In other words, we pick
an 'x' and fixed it.
That means that that
stays constant.
But as 'n' goes to infinity,
the denominator increases
without bound.
That makes the limit
equal to 0.
And 0 is obviously less than
1, regardless of what the
value of 'x' happens
to be here.
In other words, in this
particular case, this
particular series converges for
all real values of 'x'.
And we sometimes abbreviate that
by saying the absolute
value of 'x' is less
than infinity.
And therefore, the original
series, meaning the one
without the absolute value sign,
would, in particular,
converge also for
all real 'x'.
The important point is that, in
general, given any series--
in other words, limit of a
sequence of polynomials of
this particular type--
there always exists
a number 'M'.
Now, 'M' may be as small as 0.
It may be as large
as infinity.
But there always exists an 'M',
such that the particular
series will converge absolutely
if the magnitude of
'x' is less than 'M', and
diverge if the magnitude of
'x' is greater than 'M'.
In other words, this particular
'M', which is
called the radius of
convergence, governs the
answer to the first question.
In other words, it's this 'M',
which we often find by the
ratio test, that determines
where the sequence of
functions, ''P sub n' of x', for
what values of 'x', that
will converge to 'P of x'.
And again, I think this is kind
of difficult for you to
see abstractly.
The proof is done in the text.
What I'd like to do is show
you pictorially what's
happening over here.
See, let's suppose we have
our series, summation
'a n 'x to the n''.
And we pick a particular value
of 'x', say 'x sub 1'.
Now, the idea is this.
If this particular series
converges--
and the proof is given in the
text, and I won't repeat it
here because I want you to
see the overview here--
if this particular series
converges--
in other words, if the series
converges when 'x' is equal to
'x sub 1'--
then it can be shown that it
converges absolutely for any
'x' which is smaller in
magnitude then 'x sub 1'.
In other words, the
gist is this.
If I know that the series
converges over here, I can
then draw this interval
surrounding 0, and conclude
that the series converges
in this entire interval.
Correspondingly, if this
particular series diverges--
and by the way, the whole proof
of this thing hinges on
the comparison test,
essentially.
See, if this thing diverges,
then certainly, if 'x' is
larger than 'x1' in magnitude,
this will also diverge.
In other words, once I know
that my series diverges at
this particular value
of 'x1'..
of 'x', I know it diverges for
all values of 'x' which are
greater in magnitude then 'x1',
which means, in terms of
a picture, for everything
further away from 0, then 'x1'
and minus 'x1'.
In other words, if this
converges, this converges.
In here, if this diverges, we
have divergence out here.
Now, what does that mean?
Let me show you again in terms
of a extended diagram.
See, the idea goes something
like this.
Given the series summation 'a n
'x to the n'', pick a number
'x' equal to 'x1'.
Suppose the series converges
at 'x1'.
Then we know that it converges
every place in here, so
there's no need to check
this any further.
What we do next is we
pick a number, 'x2',
outside of this interval.
Say 'x2' is over here.
Suppose, for the sake of
argument-- see, what we're
saying is 'a n 'x 1 to the
n'' converges, so you
just suppose this.
That gives us this picture.
Suppose 'a n 'x2 to
the n'' diverges.
Then we know that the series
diverges for all
larger values of 'x'.
Now we know how the series
behaves exactly, except in the
interval between
'x1' and 'x2'.
So what we do next is what?
We pick a number which
we'll call 'x3'.
We then see whether this
converges or diverges.
If it converges at 'x3', we
know that the radius of
convergence extends all
the way between minus
'x3' and plus 'x3'.
If it diverges, we know that,
from 'x3' out and minus 'x3'
out, the series diverges.
In any event, each time we
perform this operation, we cut
the remaining space down.
And we can keep on
going this way.
And you see what you're doing
then, is you're zeroing in on
this number that we called
capital 'M' before.
You see, it's just a series
of refinements.
And by the way, the
formal proof of
this looks very messy.
And yet, when it's stripped of
all embellishment, that's
exactly what the formal
proof says.
Well, at any rate, I will
reinforce the rest of this
between the text, the notes,
and the learning exercises.
All I want to do now is talk
about the second question.
In other words, we've now talked
about something called
the radius of convergence, that
tells us when the series
of functions converges to
the limit function.
Now the question is, how can we
measure whether that limit
function converges to the
original function that we're
trying to approximate?
In other words, how do we know
whether 'P of x' actually
equals 'f of x'?
And again, this is done
extremely well in the text.
It's called Taylor's theorem
with remainder.
The proof is given very,
very nicely.
I think the hardest part is to
show what the thing means.
You see, using integration
by parts repeatedly--
which is done in the text--
it follows that, if 'f' and
its first 'n plus 1'
derivatives exist at 'x' equals
0, it turns out-- and
this is why this is called
Taylor's theorem with
remainder--
it turns out that 'f of x' can
be written as 'Pn of x' plus a
remainder term-- ''r sub n'
of x'-- a remainder term.
And then you see,
computationally, the text
shows what that remainder
term looks like.
It happens to be the integral
from 0 to 'x', ''x minus t' to
the n-th' over 'n factorial',
'n plus first' derivative of
'f of t', 'dt', from 't' equals
0 to 't' equals 'x'.
This looks messy.
It is messy.
There's no need to hammer this
home in the lecture part of
our course.
What I prefer to do is to give
several learning exercises
that will give you drill
in using this.
But the point that I want you
to understand is that, since
this is all done well in the
text, all I want you to do is
to see where this
thing fits in.
In other words, what the text
is showing is, look it, the
difference between the
function which we're
approximating at 0 comma 'f
of 0' by this sequence of
polynomials, the difference
between that function and the
nth member of that sequence
of polynomials is simply
something called ''r sub n' of
x', where numerically ''r sub
n' of x' looks like this.
And the point is that, if you
now take the limit of this
expression as 'n' goes to
infinity, remember, 'P of x'
is this limit.
Therefore, the only way that 'P
of x' can equal 'f of x' is
if, for a given value of 'x',
this remainder goes to 0 as
'n' goes to infinity.
In other words, leaving the
computational details to the
text, because it does it very
nicely, what we're saying is
that the significance of
Taylor's remainder theorem is
that, to find out where 'f of x'
and 'P of x' are identical,
we simply--
and I say simply meaning
conceptually simply--
computationally, it might
be difficult.
What we do computationally is
simply find all those values
of 'x', for which ''r sub n' of
x' goes to 0 in the limit
as 'n' goes to infinity.
You see, what we've done is
we've now done two things.
We've first shown when
the sequence of
polynomials has a limit.
And secondly, we've shown when
it does have a limit, when
will it equal the given
function that
it's trying to represent.
The question that still remains
is, how do we know
that the limit function has the
same properties as each
member of the sequence?
In fact, we've just given an
example where the limit
function had different
properties.
And the question is, under what
conditions can we be sure
that certain nice results--
that we'd like to be true,
because they're true about
each polynomial in
the sequence--
actually are true about
the limit function.
In fact, that shall
be our topic for
the next two lessons.
And these next two lectures
should complete the course.
At any rate, until next
time, goodbye.
MALE SPEAKER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.